[Musique]
parce que l'europe c'est le seul moyen
pour d'un pays comme le nôtre pour nos
pays de se rassembler d'avoir une
puissance suffisante pour ne pas subir
les grandes puissances continentales qui
se sont installées dans le monde les
états unis la chine l'inde la russie et
quelques autres séparer nous allons être
débordés et il n'y a pas que face à des
pays il ya aussi face à de grandes
puissances économiques
songez par exemple qu'en matière
d'intelligence artificielle google une
entreprise américaine seuls les 15
milliards d'euros dans la sueur la
recherche cette année pendant que nos
pays séparé 27 pays met 8 milliards ça
veut dire qu'on va être largué
technologiquement si on ne se
rassemblent pas qu'on n'a pas une
politique industrielle commune
on a besoin également de se renforcer
pour protéger nos frontières pour un
éveil et un parquet européen contre les
terroristes et les grands trafiquants on
a besoin de re d'augmenter le budget de
la politique agricole commune pour
garantir notre suffit de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire tous à nos
pays n'ont plus le poids de le faire
seul l'europe est en danger
elle peut disparaître contrairement à ce
que tout le monde pense est une des
raisons pour lesquelles dans nos
propositions nous cherchons des éléments
qui peuvent rassembler les européens
c'est parce que il faut reconstruire
cette unité comme jacques delors avait
su le faire à un moment où l'europe
était déjà en difficulté c'était dans
les années 80 nous proposons qu'il n'y
ait plus de contributions nationales
pour alimenter le budget européen
c'est 91 milliards pour andré à la
france mais c'est aussi beaucoup
d'argent pour andré aux autres remplacer
comme à l'origine comme du temps de jean
monnet par des contributions extérieures
une taxe sur l'importation de carbone
qui rapporterait 70 milliards une taxe
sur les transactions financières taxe
très minime 0 0 1% mais c'est bien
normal que
ils contribuent au fonctionnement de
l'union européenne il ya bien d'autres
propositions pour faire avancer l'europe
car si elle n'avance pas nous subirons
le poids les intérêts du reste du monde
et si ce sont leurs intérêts c'est que
ce sont pas les nôtres nous proposons
une europe qui se rassemblent qui soit
capable sur un certain nombre de sujets
de dire ça on va le faire ensemble
je prends l'exemple des bateaux le
premier bateau à hydrogène autonome il
est français on devrait mettre le
maximum sur ce genre de technologie pour
permettre par exemple que demain on
risque plus de marée de voir comme on en
a vu encore il ya pas longtemps dans le
golfe de gascogne
parce que si un bateau fonctionne à
l'hydrogène si j'avais eu un accident
s'est jamais qu de l'an de l'hydrogène
dans l'eau d'hydrogène dans l'eau c'est
bien là rassemblés on peut à la fois
économiser les énergies isoler le
bâtiment développer la production de
l'énergie renouvelable et propre est
d'ailleurs en faire un secteur
d'exportation vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
mais on peut aussi utiliser le fait que
nous sommes une grande puissance
commerciale nous achetons beaucoup de
choses à l'étranger pour imposer nos
règles normes
[Musique]